PLAYERS ASSOCIATION AND THE
NFL CONTINUE TO GRAPPLE OVER
THE ISSUE OF OFFSEASON
WORKOUTS PLAYERS.
NOT SHOWING UP THE UNION
TRYING TO GET AS MANY PLAYERS
AS POSSIBLE TO NOT SHOW UP
THE WEEK BEGAN WITH A
CONFERENCE CALL BETWEEN THE
UNION LEADERSHIP ROOKIES AND
THEIR AGENTS BECAUSE THE
UNION IS TRYING TO GET THE
ROOKIES NOT TO SHOW UP, WHICH
IS KIND OF A LUDICROUS
PROPOSITION. ANYBODY DRAFTED
BELOW ROUND 3, IF YOU DON'T
SHOW UP FOR THE OFFSEASON
PROGRAM VOLUNTARILY, YOU'RE
GONNA HAVE A HARD TIME MAKING
THE TEAM THE LATER YOU'RE
DRAFTED, THE HARDER IT'S
GOING TO BE TO MAKE THE THE
53-MAN ROSTER AND IF YOU'RE
ON DRAFTED YOU IMAGINE AN
TWO PLAYER JUST DAYS AFTER
SIGNING THE CONTRACT AS AN
UNDRAFTED ROOKIE, NOT GOOD
ENOUGH TO BE DRAFTED IN ANY
OF THE SEVEN ROUNDS. YOU KNOW
TO THE OFFICE. OING TO COME
WORKOUTS, IT'S ONLY ABOUT A
NINE PACK YOUR BAG. AND
SPEAKING OF PACKING YOUR BAGS,
YOU CAN UNPACK YOUR BAG IN A
HOTEL AT THE TEAM FACILITY,
NOT TEAM FACILITY BUT YOU
KNOW, A DOOR AROUND THE TEAM
BUT, YOU KNOW, A DOOR AROUND
THE TEAM FACILITY, THEY PUT
YOU IN LODGING. THEY FEED YOU.
YOU HAVE A TRANSITION PERIOD
UNTIL YOU FIND A PLACE TO
LIVE IN THE CITY WHERE YOU
ARE GOING TO BE RESIDING. SO
THERE'S PLENTY OF REASONS TO
DO IT. IF YOU'RE A ROOKIE IN
THIS, JUST ILLUSTRATES THE
SERIOUS CONFLICTS OF INTEREST
AMONG THE VARIOUS MEMBERS OF
THIS UNION, SOME IT'S IN
SHOW UP FOR THE OFFSEASON
PROGRAM, OTHERS, IT'S IN
THEIR INTEREST TO BE THERE
BUT THAT'S NOT STOPPING THE
UNION FROM TRYING TO GET AS
MANY PLAYERS AS POSSIBLE TO
NOT SHOW UP. AND I REALLY DO
CONTINUE TO BELIEVE IT'S A
MISTAKE MILES ESPECIALLY FOR
A ROOKIES. AND IT, I'M TOLD
THAT SOME AGENTS REALLY PUSH
BACK AGGRESSIVELY ON MONDAY
BECAUSE THEY'RE TRYING TO
REPRESENT THEIR CLIENTS AND
YOU REPRESENT YOUR CLIENT YOU
TELL YOUR CLIENT YOU GET YOUR
BUTT IN THERE. DON'T LISTEN
TO YOUR UNION. LISTEN TO ME
IT'S IN YOUR BEST INTEREST TO
GET IN THERE. ABSOLUTELY.
LOOK I THINK IF YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT ROOKIE MINICAMP
JUST
SOME TEAMS MAY DO IT
DIFFERENTLY THAN OTHERS, BUT
THE ONES THAT I'VE BEEN
AROUND THE ONES THAT I'VE
BEEN AROUND THE ONES THAT
I'VE SEEN USUALLY THEY'RE
VERY, VERY SCALED BACK.
EVERYTHING IN TERMS OF WHAT
IS GOING ON ON THE FIELD,
IT'S MORE LIKE I WOULD EQUATE
IT TO BASICALLY A FRESHMAN
ORIENTATION WHEN YOU'RE GOING
TO COLLEGE, BASICALLY, YOU'RE
JUST TRYING TO GET INTO THE
BUILDING. YOU'RE TRYING TO
MEET YOUR COACHES, YOUR
MEETING YOUR NEW TEAMMATES,
YOU'RE SEEING YOUR LOCKER FOR
THE FIRST TIME, YOU'RE SEEING
YOUR HELMET FOR THE FIRST
TIME, YOU KNOW, MAYBE YOU YOU
GET IT, YOUR JERSEY FITTED
FOR THE
THE FIRST TIME IN EVERYTHING
LIKE THAT, YOU KNOW, YOU'RE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHERE
THE CAFETERIA IS WHERE YOUR
MEETING ROOM IS YOU'RE NOT
GOING OUT THERE, GOING
THROUGH A FULL PRACTICE AND
EVERYTHING. SO I THINK IT IS
KIND OF, LIKE YOU SAID, IT'S
A LITTLE LUDICROUS TO SAY. OH
NO, ROOKIES. OH, GO TO THE
ROOKIE MINICAMP. YOU DON'T
NEED TO DO THAT. WELL, I MEAN,
YOU KIND OF DO BECAUSE
OTHERWISE, IF YOU'RE JUST
GOING TO SAY NO, I'M NOT
GOING TO ANY PART OF THIS
OFFSEASON PROGRAM IN. YOU'RE
A ROOKIE THEN YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO KNOW YOUR HEAD AND
FROM YOUR FEET WHEN YOU
ACTUALLY END UP
IN THE TEAM FACILITY FOR THE
FIRST TIME FOR TRAINING CAMP
AND TO ME THAT DOESN'T REALLY
MAKE ANY SENSE. SO I THINK IT
MAKES A LOT OF SENSE FOR
AGENTS TO SAY, ESPECIALLY IF
THEY'RE GUYS, ARE DRAFTED
ROUND 3 OR LATER? NO, NO. YOU
ACTUALLY REALLY NEED TO BE
IN THERE AND IN THE BUILDING
AND NOT JUST FOR A ROOKIE
MINICAMP FOR THE ENTIRE
OFFSEASON PROGRAM, BECAUSE
THAT'S THE ONLY WAY YOU'RE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO MAKE THE
TEAM IS IF YOU ESTABLISH
TRUST WITH THIS COACHING
STAFF, THE ONLY WAY FOR YOU
TO REALLY DO THAT IS TO BE
IT'S ALL THE SENSE IN THE
WORLD FOR ROOKIES TO BE AT
ROOKIE MINICAMP AND THEN THE
YEAH. AND YOU KNOW, APART
FROM GETTING YOURSELF
SITUATED. GETTING YOURSELF
ORIENTED GETTING YOURSELF,
COMFORTABLE FOR TRAINING CAMP.
YOU'RE, SHOWING THE COACH,
YOU GIVE A CRAP AND THAT'S
ONE OF THE INGREDIENTS, IN
GETTING THE COACH, TO DECIDE
THAT YOU ARE SOMEBODY WHO
WILL BE ON THE TEAM WHEN
LABOR DAY WEEKEND ROLLS
AROUND. AND THAT'S ONE OF THE
FUNDAMENTAL PROBLEMS WITH
THIS UNION. THE INTERESTS OF
THE RANK AND FILE ARE TWO
DIVERGENT, WHETHER IT'S THE
POSITION THAT YOU PLAY
WHETHER IT'S THE WHOLE
CONCEPT OF THE SALARY CAP,
EVERYONE'S EATING OUT OF THE
SAME PIE AMONG
VARIOUS NFL FRANCHISES.
THERE'S 90 JOBS THAT SHRINK
253, YOU DON'T USUALLY HAVE
THAT KIND OF COMPETITION
AMONG YOUR WORKFORCE, WHERE
IT'S A ZERO SUM GAME. AND FOR
EVERY GUY WHO GETS A JOB,
THERE'S GOING TO BE ANOTHER
ONE. ROUGHLY, THE ODDS ARE
ALMOST ONE-TO-ONE. THAT YOU
GOING TO BE CUT 53, STAY 37,
GO. IT'S A LITTLE OVER HALF
THAT MAKE IT, BUT AND THEN
YOU'RE ALWAYS AT RISK OF
BEING CUT. IF YOU DO, MAKE IT
FOR ONE OF YOUR UNION
BROTHERS, WHO WOULD COME IN
IT REALLY IS A WEIRD
SITUATION ALTOGETHER. JAY
FEELY HAD A TWEET TODAY THAT
I THINK BEARS. MENTIONING HE
SAYS I WAITED TWO YEARS AFTER
COLLEGE TO GET INVITED TO
SIGN WITH AN NFL TEAM. THERE
IS NO WAY. I WOULDN'T HAVE
GONE TO OFFSEASON WORKOUTS.
DON'T ASK THESE YOUNG PLAYERS
TO RISK THEIR DREAMS FOR A
BARGAINING, CHIP FOR VETERANS
WHO PREFER TO WORK OUT ON
THEIR OWN. AND, YOU KNOW,
THAT'S THE REALITY, THE
AND THEY DON'T WANT THE YOUNG
PLAYERS TO BE THERE. PRESSING
THE COACHES, MAKING THE
COACHES COMFORTABLE AND
MAKING THE COACHES.
SAY, YOU KNOW WHAT, LET'S
KEEP THE GUY WHO'S MAKING 800,
000 THIS YEAR AND CUT THE GUY
YEAR AND CUT THE GUY WHO'S
MAKING SEVEN MILLION. OF
COURSE. LOOK, EVERYBODY'S
TRYING TO LOOK OUT FOR THEIR
BEST INTERESTS. AND IF YOU
ARE A VETERAN, THEN SURE, I
EXACTLY WHY YOU WOULD SAY, NO,
SHOULD BE AT THESE OFFSEASON
WORKOUTS BECAUSE THAT IS WHAT
YOUR BEST INTEREST IS AND
FRANKLY I MEAN IT'S STILL
VOLUNTARY, RIGHT? SO
THE REASON THAT YOU DON'T
NEED TO GO IS BECAUSE IT'S
VOLUNTARY AND IF YOU'RE GOOD
ENOUGH, THEN IN THEORY YOU
SHOULD STILL BE ABLE TO GET
IN YOUR WORK IN THE OFFSEASON
PROGRAM OR DURING THE
OFFSEASON PROGRAM. WHEN IT'S
GOING ON, IF YOUR OFF-SITE
AND YOU CAN SAY, LOOK, I'M
STILL GOING TO BE MY SAME GUY.
I'M STILL GOING TO BE THE
SAME PLAYER. I MIGHT EVEN BE
BETTER THAN I WAS LAST YEAR,
I'LL PROVE IT TO YOU IN
TRAINING CAMP. NOW. OBVIOUSLY,
PROBLEM WITH THAT IS YOU
MIGHT GET SUPPLANTED BY
SOMEBODY, WHO'S THERE? AND
GETTING THE INSTRUCTION EVERY
SINGLE DAY. AND SO,
SO FROM A VETERAN STANDPOINT,
YES, I DO UNDERSTAND WHY IT
THAT THEY WOULD WANT NONE OF
THIS TO BE HAPPENING AT THIS
POINT IN TIME IN THE
OFFSEASON. BUT IF YOU'RE A
YOUNG PLAYER, I MEAN YOU GOT
TO LOOK AT THAT. AND YOU
JUST GOTTA SAY, MAN, I LIKE
JAY FEELY JUST SAID, I DON'T
WANT TO PUT MY DREAMS ON HOLD
OR MAYBE TAKE A STEP BACK
FROM WHAT I WOULD BE ABLE TO
DO JUST BECAUSE IT BENEFITS
YOU AND THAT REALLY IS THE
PROBLEM WITH WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING HERE. IN THIS ZERO SUM
GAME BECAUSE IT REALLY JUST
IS THAT. I MEAN,
IS KIND OF NO WAY FOR THIS TO
NOT BE AS IT CURRENTLY IS,
RIGHT BECAUSE OF THE WAY,
ARE CONSTRUCTED BECAUSE OF
THE WAY ROSTERS ARE
CONSTRUCTED BECAUSE OF THE
WAY THE SALARY CAP IS SO LOOK
IT. IF YOU'RE A YOUNG PLAYER,
MAKES ALL THE SENSE IN THE
WORLD FOR YOU TO GO TO WORK,
YOU JUST WHETHER IT'S
VOLUNTARY OR NOT, YOU JUST
NEED TO BE THERE SO THAT YOU
ESTABLISH THAT TRUST WHEN
YOU'RE OLDER, IF YOU'RE GOOD
ENOUGH THEN YEAH YOU CAN STAY
AWAY ALL YOU WANT BUT I
DON'T KNOW THAT IT'S REALLY
FAIR FOR THESE YOUNGER
PLAYERS FOR THE OLDER PLAYERS
SAY KNOW, EVERYBODY NEEDS TO
DO EXACTLY WHAT WE SAY THAT
THEY HAVE TO DO WHEN IT'S
PROBABLY NOT IN THEIR BEST
INTEREST AND EVERYBODY KIND
OF KNOWS THAT.
YEAH, YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT
ABOUT THAT. THE UNION?
NEVERTHELESS STILL PUSHING
THE ISSUE. THERE WAS A
CONFERENCE CALL TODAY THAT
WAS AVAILABLE TO ALL PLAYERS.
I'D LOVE TO KNOW HOW MANY
PLAYERS ACTUALLY WERE ON IT
BECAUSE A VERY SMALL
PERCENTAGE OF THEM,
UNDERSTAND THE ISSUES OR EVEN
CARE FOR O'CLOCK EASTERN ON A
FRIDAY AFTERNOON. I SUSPECT
YOUR PARTICIPATION RATE IS
GOING TO BE EXTREMELY LOW BUT
TOM BRADY, THE BUCCANEERS
QUARTERBACK WAS ON THE CALL
AND HE ARGUED THAT THE
PLAYERS SHOULD PUSH FOR
MODIFICATIONS TO THE
OFFSEASON PROGRAM AND THAT
SEEMS TO BE WHAT THIS
ALL ABOUT TRYING TO GET THE
LEAGUE TO AGREE TO SOMETHING,
OTHERWISE THEY'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO DO THIS EVERY
YEAR. AND THEY'RE GOING TO
ENCOURAGE YOU GUYS TO STAY
AWAY EVERY YEAR, AND IT'S
GOING TO BE THIS ANNOYANCE
EVERY YEAR. THAT'S STILL NOT
THE BEST LEVERAGE. YOU KNOW,
THE BEST LEVERAGE FOR THE
UNION. CAME TWICE, LAST YEAR,
THEY NEGOTIATED A NEW CBA IN
MARCH. FINALIZED IT IN MARCH,
NEGOTIATED FOR MONTHS, BEFORE
THAT LEAGUE WANTS 17 GAMES.
IF YOU AS THE UNION WANTS
STUFF, THAT DOESN'T COST THE
OWNERS ANY MONEY.
AND THAT'S WHEN YOU ASK FOR
IT BECAUSE YOU'RE LIKELY TO
GET IT BECAUSE THE OWNERS
SAY WHAT'S THAT COST? AS IT
DOESN'T COST YOU ANYTHING?
WELL, HELL YEAH, LET'S DO IT.
SO THEY COULD HAVE ASKED FOR
IT. THEN MILES LAST JULY WHEN
THEY ESSENTIALLY REOPENED THE
CBA AND RENEGOTIATED IT TO
ALLOW PRO FOOTBALL TO PROCEED
LAST YEAR DURING THE PANDEMIC,
THAT WAS ANOTHER OCCASION TO
DO IT. AND THERE'S A THIRD
TIME THEY COULD HAVE DONE IT
WHEN THEY NEGOTIATED THE
SALARY CAP THIS YEAR. HEY, BY
THE WAY, BY THE WAY, LET'S
MODIFY THE
OFFSEASON.
AND FOR THIS YEAR AND THEN
MAYBE NEXT YEAR, YOU HAVE AN
OCCASION TO MAKE IT MORE
PERMANENT. I THINK THAT THEIR
STRATEGY HERE IS TO CREATE
CHAOS TO BE AN IRRITANT TO BE
AN ANNOYANCE TO THE POINT
WHERE THE LEAGUE FINALLY SAYS.
OKAY, HOW ABOUT THIS? HOW
ABOUT THIS? IF WE CUT IT IN
HALF, WILL YOU AGREE TO SHOW
UP? IF WE DO THESE OTHER
STOP DOING THIS EVERY SINGLE
YEAR, I JUST THINK THAT
, I THINK IT'S A MISTAKE.
IT'S NOT IN THE BEST INTEREST
OF MOST PLAYERS. IT'S
DEFINITELY NOT IN THE
INTEREST OF JUWAN, JAMES MORE
ON HIM IN A SECOND. AND I
LOOK, I LIKE THE FACT THAT
TOM BRADY IS ON BOARD WITH
WHAT THE NFLPA IS
RECOMMENDING, BUT HE'S THE
GUY LAST YEAR MILES, WHEN THE
UNION SAID DON'T GET TOGETHER
AND WORK OUT DURING THE
PANDEMIC AWAY FROM THE
FACILITY UNTIL TRAINING CAMP
OPENS. THEY KEPT DRAGGING
GUYS TO THE PRACTICE FIELD.
FIELD TO WORK OUT. SO ALL OF
A SUDDEN HE'S ON BOARD WITH
WHAT THE UNION WANTS HIM TO
DO. YEAH. AND NOW HE'S
TALKING ABOUT, YOU KNOW, THE
MLB PITCHERS. DON'T THROW, 95
MILE AN HOUR FASTBALL IN THE
OFFSEASON. WELL, I MEAN, DUDE
THE ONE THAT WAS GETTING
TOGETHER WITH ALL YOUR GUYS
AND YOU WERE THROWING TO
ESTABLISH CHEMISTRY IN THE
OFF SEASON AND LAST YEAR. SO
MEAN, YOU KNOW, THE ONLY
THING WE HAVE TO FEAR IS FEAR
ITSELF, RIGHT? YES, EXACTLY.
I DON'T KNOW. WE'RE ONE WEEK
CLOSER TO DEATH. THAT'S YOUR
YES, IT SOUNDS LIKE CHAOS IS
A LADDER. CAN YOU SAY, YOU
KNOW, THEY'RE TRYING TO
CREATE CHAOS?
I MEAN, SOMEBODY ONCE SAID
THAT CHAOS IS A LADDER MAN
AND I JUST FEEL LIKE IN THIS
CASE, THE LADDERS NOT GOING
UP THERE, TAKING THE LADDER
RIGHT ON DOWN BECAUSE IT'S
NOT CREATING THE TYPE OF
ENVIRONMENT THAT THEY NEEDED
TO CREATE IN ORDER TO MAKE
SOME SORT OF LEVERAGE. THEY
HAVE NO LEVERAGE, RIGHT? LIKE
YOU JUST SAID I MEAN IF THEY
REALLY WANTED TO DO THIS AND
GET THAT THE OFFSEASON
PROGRAM, MODIFIED CANCELED,
WHATEVER YOU DO THAT. WHEN
YOU'RE TRYING TO NEGOTIATE
FOR 17 GAMES, THAT THAT
REALLY IS A CHIP BECAUSE NOT
THE OWNER  NOT GOING TO COST
HAS ANY MONEY TO GET RID OF?
GOING TO COST THEM LESS MONEY.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO HAVE TO
IN THEORY, SPEND MONEY, ON
HOTELS, AND PER DIEM. AND,
KNOW, FOOD AND GIVING FOOD,
TO ALL THESE PLAYERS, AND
THINGS LIKE THAT. SO I JUST
FEEL LIKE THERE WAS A TIME
FOR THEM TO DO THIS IT JUST
ISN'T NOW BECAUSE OF I'M AN
OWNER. I'M SAYING WAIT A
MINUTE. WE LITERALLY JUST
NEGOTIATED THIS LAST YEAR.
IT'S IS A NEW CBA. I'M NOT
I'M NOT TAKING THE I'M NOT
TRYING TO TAKE SOMETHING ELSE
AWAY FROM MY COACHES WHO WERE
ALREADY UPSET. WHEN WE PAIRED
THIS,
THING DOWN, YOU KNOW, THE
LAST TIME WE NEGOTIATED CBA,
2011 THE COACHES ARE THE ONES
THAT DON'T LIKE THIS SO IF
IT'S NOT GOING TO COST THE
OWNERS ANY MONEY? YEAH,
THAT'S ONE THING, BUT AT THIS
POINT WHEN YOU JUST
NEGOTIATED THIS WHOLE THING
IT MAKES NO SENSE FROM THAT
STANDPOINT FOR THEM TO TAKE
IT DOWN EVEN FURTHER.
AND PROVING THAT THE NFL
REALLY WANTS THIS. EVEN
THOUGH THE OWNERS DEEP DOWN
DON'T CARE, THE MEMO THAT WAS
SENT ON WEDNESDAY AFTER THE
JUWAN JAMES INJURY, THE MEMO
AFTER THE JUWAN JAMES INJURY,
THE MEMO TO ALL TEAMS,
REMINDING THEM OF SOMETHING
THEY'VE KNOWN SINCE 1977 THAT
ARE PLAY. IF A PLAYER GETS
INJURED AWAY FROM THE
FACILITY, THE PLAYER DOESN'T
GET PAID OR MORE ACCURATELY
THE TEAM CAN CHOOSE NOT TO
PAY THE PLAYER. THE NFLPA
RESPONDED TO THAT YESTERDAY
BY CALLING IT GUTLESS AND A
SCARE TACTIC AIMED AT GETTING
PLAYERS TO SHOW UP. WELL, IT
MAY HAVE BEEN AND I THINK
IT WAS, BUT THE PLAYERS NEED
TO HAVE SOMEONE TELLING THEM
ALL. HERE ARE THE RISKS IF D AW